[Musique]
les oubliés de l'Europe c'est vous c'est
nous c'est les artisans les commerçants
les professions libérales et les
indépendants les auto-entrepreneurs les
intermittents du spectacle mais c'est
aussi les retraités les retraités de ces
professions qui n'ont pas compté leurs
heures pendant toute leur carrière qui
faisaient de longues journées qui se
levaient très tôt qui se couchaient très
tard qui avait très peu de vacances peu
de week-end peu de soirée toujours
présents pour répondre aux demandes de
leurs clients pour former les jeunes au
niveau de l'apprentissage et surtout
transmettre transmettre leur
savoir-faire aux jeunes générations nous
au niveau des oubliés de l'Europe nous
avons surtout décidé de communiquer via
les réseaux sociaux via Internet nous
avons mis en place donc une page
Facebook un compte Instagram un compte
Twitter les bulletins de vote sont aussi
disponibles sur notre site Internet pour
ceux qui veulent l'imprimer
penser justement aux économies
environnementales et au respect de
l'environnement moins de papiers c'est
aussi mieux pour nous tous au niveau
Europe
[Musique]
nous sommes les oubliés de l'Europe
puisque nous faisons partie des 90% de
ceux qui font l'économie nationale mais
malheureusement c'est les 10% qui
restent qui décident de toutes les lois
européennes de toutes les directives de
toutes les normes donc les 90% sont
totalement oubliés et nous sommes tous
oubliés
[Musique]
les axes forts pour voter pour les
oubliés de l'Europe c'est justement de
défendre ses professions les artisans
les commerçants les professions
libérales et les indépendants nous
intervenons auprès des jeunes pour les
former au niveau de l'apprentissage nous
sommes là pour payer les taxes justement
mettre en application les normes et les
directives européennes toutes ces
directives qui malheureusement font
disparaître le savoir-faire notre
savoir-faire national et régional nous
cherchons à justement participer à ces
élections européennes pour faire partie
vraiment de ces de ces nouvelles
directives les électeurs sont demandeurs
de ce type de liste sans étiquette
politique il faut pas l'oublier nous ne
sommes rattachés à aucun parti et nous
voulons garder notre indépendance
[Musique]